Hamilton starred daveed Diggs is asking
Americans to look at Independence Day
through a different lens he narrates a
new video it's knockout written by a
group of black writers it's called what
to my people is a 4th of July this is
how it starts
what to my people is the 4th of July my
people who are failed everyday by every
country sleepless in the long night we
have cried salt baths for our kin arms
help me tell me what do we tell the
children of your 4th of July boy the
videos inspired by Frederick Douglass is
addressed to the Rochester ladies
anti-slavery society back in 1852 the
black abolitionist lecture is famously
called the what to the slave is a fourth
of July speech daveed Diggs is well
known for playing founding father Thomas
Jefferson and Hamilton performance that
earned him a Tony Award he joins us from
Los Angeles to discuss we'll talk about
Hamilton in just a second too vide but I
cannot get over that video it is
powerful it is provocative your read was
perfection and I think a lot of people
saying America is looking into the
mirror these days and we don't like what
we see so I'm wondering when you first
word those work when you first read
those words for the first time what were
your thoughts and your feelings as you
were doing it I had the opportunity to
play Frederick Douglass for for an
upcoming piece for Showtime called the
good luck bird and as part of that
performance I perform excerpts from the
fourth of July from his whatever slave
is the fourth of July at speech and so I
remember the first time I read that
speech and how poignant and how
contemporary released a lot of the point
still felt 170 acting that speech and
modernizing yet I sort of just jumped at
the opportunity
and what they came up with was bringing
it it really but really I think
contextualizes and manages to capture a
lot of the feeling of the moment and a
lot of the desire to hold America
accountable and to keep those kinds of
discussions going beyond just the moment
that we're in you're so right to hold
America accountable listen from
Frederick Douglass's speech when it was
called what to the American slave is
your 4th of July he says in part a day
that reveals to him the gross injustice
and cruelty to which he is a constant
victim and though I thought I thought to
be those words were so eerie and so sad
how much they still resonate today with
what is happening in this country we are
yeah I mean it's over a hundred days
since Brianna Taylor was murdered and we
you know there have been no charges yet
where we are we are constantly
confronted with a with a difference in
value of our lives and so to
particularly as we reflect on this
moment of the fourth of July and what
we're celebrating this idea independence
it's complicated I think for a fella to
figure out how we fit into that
celebration know for instance in the
video that you that you narrated says
police parade down streets proud
descendents of the slave patrol and I've
heard that you two have had very
unpleasant encounters with the police
would you talk about that yeah you know
um you'd be hard-pressed to find anybody
black who hasn't just to some degree
right but I between the ages of 22 and
25 I got pulled over maybe almost forty
something times never got a ticket I
days before I left at Los Angeles to go
start performing Hamilton at the Public
Theater I got snatched off on my bicycle
by police officers and thrown up against
a fence because I faded description I
yeah and I have also had
so always to say it's not it's not a
condemnation of any specific police
officer but of a system that is is
trained to treat black life differently
mm-hmm you know I have to talk about
Hamilton which is streaming on Disney
Plus tonight I can't believe that we
have you on this particular day because
I'm told that you were sent an advance
copy and you didn't watch it people
people would kill to watch it de vie
they would kill to watch it people will
get to see this for the first time I'm
so psyched about this yeah yeah me too
and I have yet to watch it but now
everybody can it's out streaming on
Disney Plus and I think there's a great
sense of patriotism that comes along
with watching that show and I think
that's important to think about today
especially you know thank you James
Baldwin said a night to be exact oh okay
okay yeah I understand James Baldwin
said in 55 I love America more than any
other country in the world and exactly
for this reason I insist on the right to
criticize her perpetually I've been
thinking about that quote a lot as I go
into this weekend yeah it makes a lot of
sense to me I think a lot of people are
asking questions that they've never
asked before I also heard you say when
you played Jefferson you have a
showstopper show stealing scene I can't
wait for people to see that that you
felt very patriotic for the first time
when you played that role
congratulations to you to be this video
is knockout in your performance and
Hamilton knockout thank you for getting
up early with us today really appreciate
it